so we're continuing our coverage of this
sort of up and down
hot and cold reporting of so-called
election fraud that's been taking place
on fox news and we are now getting to
laura ingram we talked about tucker
carlson earlier today now we're going to
talk about laura ingraham and this is
really very funny
you are going to see video now of laura
ingram
very slowly and carefully and gently
explaining to her audience donald trump
is not getting another four years joe
biden is going to be the president of
the united states
and this is so funny because it's sort
of like it's like a mid-level mafia guy
having to go in and tell the godfather
things didn't go so well
or you know an employee having to go in
and tell their intimidating boss
that they're not going to make the sales
target for the
quarter or something like that you know
tiptoeing around the tooth
listen sir we we really put in our best
effort
it's starting to look like maybe
through no fault of our own the
bad guy might have gotten away or
something like that
and she has to speak to her audience
almost like they're
not all there but she does tell them
i would be lying if i kept pretending
that donald trump was going to figure
out how to get a second term now
where she is still being deceptive is
that it was just as deceptive two weeks
ago to pretend like donald trump might
be on his way to a second term we knew
he wasn't
but take a look at this video this is
laura ingram explaining
that thanks to donald trump as i already
told you
formally okaying the transition to start
it really is like a concession take a
look president trump
gave the go-ahead for the transition you
see it there
and as unpleasant and disappointing as
these past three weeks have been to so
many of us
as much as we wish things were different
this is where things stand tonight
now legal challenges continue in a
number of states serious questions about
vote counting
poll watcher access are outstanding but
unless the legal situation changes in a
dramatic and frankly and unlikely manner
joe biden will be inaugurated
on january 20th now to say this
does not mean i don't think that this
election was
rife with problems and potential fraud
and to say this does not constitute
being a sellout to the conservative
populist movement that i've been
fighting for for i don't know 25 years
you know how some people sometimes get
mad at me
when i issue these disclaimers when i
cover certain stories
i'll say you know listen i'm going to
tell you an example of a fox news
a reporter telling the truth but this
doesn't mean we like fox news now when
it doesn't mean i'm in favor of fox news
listen to the disclaimers that laura has
to give
to protect herself from the fox news
audience which
what what's fascinating is fox news has
so
dramatically radicalized their own
audience
that the fox news audience is now too
radical
for any truth to be given to them on fox
news if they
say as some reporters did earlier on
trump lost joe biden's the
president-elect
the fox news audience is so radical that
they bail and they go to newsmax or to
oan and laura ingram has to say
guys i'm not selling out really i'm for
the conservative movement but
sorry sorry joe biden is going to be
president don't kill the messenger don't
go out i'm just the messenger here
and as i was watching that's what i was
thinking about and and the other thing
by the way
imagine being someone who
you're watching this episode last night
and this is the first time
you're hearing anyone say to you joe
biden really is going to be president
like we know trump convinced 86 of his
voters
that joe biden actually stole it and we
know donald trump
convinced 60 percent of his voters that
these bogus legal challenges
really are going to overturn the
election results i'm imagining
someone who hasn't paid attention to
actual news for the last three weeks
and thought trump is about to overturn
this thing
what are they going through turning on
laura ingram last night
and being devastated and shocked to hear
that on november 23rd for the first time
they are being told guys joe biden
really is going to be
president bizarre alternate universe
that some people are living in
let's watch a little bit more of this
and she keeps doing these
hilarious disclaimers and apologies uh
and it does not mean that i disagree at
all with the president's right and
obligation to pursue
all legitimate legal challenges to this
outcome
to say this constitutes living in
reality
and if i offered you a false reality if
i told you that there was an
excellent phenomenal chance that the
supreme court was going to step in and
deliver a victory to president trump
i'd be lying to you now you've known me
for a long time now and
you long you know me long enough to know
that i will not lie to you or simply
tell you what you want to hear
the funny thing is all these fox news
people
have been offering false realities for
weeks
she it's like performance art she says i
wouldn't lie to you
i wouldn't deceive you i'm not going to
tell you as of november 23rd yesterday
that donald trump really has a shot but
what she
and tucker and hannity have been doing
for weeks is exactly that
it's no more wrong now than it was two
weeks ago
uh when they were saying here is donald
trump's path here is the way that donald
trump could ultimately be president
you had to be a fool to fall for it then
just like now it's no clearer now than
it was two weeks ago that
of course joe biden is going to be the
next president he's been
the apparent winner for going on a month
or just short of it
i am curious to see what fox news
uh sort of looks like over the next
couple of months how much do they
continue to cow tower to
and placate their more extreme audience
the types of people who
for the first time ever were hearing
yesterday from laura ingram hey guys by
the way
joe biden's going to be the next
president for a limited time our sponsor
purevpn is offering you a huge
86 discount on a subscription
which comes out to only about a dollar
fifty per month
purevpn makes you anonymous when you're
browsing online and you can trust them
because they're the only vpn in the
industry with an
always-on third-party audit to verify
that your internet activity is not being
logged by hiding your ip address purevpn
keeps you safe
from hackers and prevents you from being
spied on by your internet service
provider
social media companies and even
government surveillance
it also lets you watch shows and movies
that aren't available in your country
purevpn is super fast you can use it on
all of your devices
and i can tell you firsthand the app is
really easy to use
and they have 6500 servers across the
world
which is more than any other vpn in the
industry
everyone should be using a vpn when
connecting to the internet and now is
the perfect time to start because
purevpn is giving you an
86 discount on a subscription which
comes out to only about a dollar fifty a
month
go to davidpakman.com purevpn
the link is underneath this video